♪ driving rock ♪
Absolutely stunning.
Because you'll see
way more of it in Europe.
Didn't expect to see that here either.
Oh, we're still not there.
Sorry, it's my judgmental nature.
I haven't seen that part of the city yet.
-Oh, you should go there.
-I should.
Pumped.
Yay!
Here in Kyiv, Ukraine
and about to go
to the far west of the country
to a city called Lviv.
I've been told it's
like a very European city.
♪ upbeat choir chanting ♪
[music fades]
Feels like a much different
Ukraine than Kyiv
or the other parts
of the country I've seen.
♪ indy rock ♪
People have always told me
"Lviv is way more European feeling."
and sure, yeah, it is... Definitely.
And coming from Kyiv,
well it's obviously smaller.
There was immediately
this chill, relaxed
sort of melodic-type feel to the place.
Everyone hanging out in the squares.
So there are a ton of cafes
a lot of restaurants
and a lot of interesting spaces here.
Like a lot of well thought out design.
[music continues]
Craft beer, craft chocolate.
There are all sort of craft products.
So I feel like there's a lot of pride
in the people here, in the culture.
[music fades]
Very good.
Very, very good coffee shop
and I met this unlucky victim, Ivan.
♪ indy rock ♪
SOLOMIA: We love you.
Tell me about this city.
I just go here.
You feel like
you're always in the city center.
Like life is always around us.
There is always something 'cause
there are plenty of festivals every day
but you just feel like
you're part of something big.
Like part of great party.
-Really?
-Yeah, seriously, yeah.
♪ traditional ♪
♪ alternative rock ♪
♪ electronic dance ♪
♪ traditional ♪
And there's a ton of art in this city.
There's art all over the place.
Lot of street music.
-Good local music scene?
-Yeah, pretty good.
Lot of musicians.
Just to come over here
and listen to some music.
Right.
♪ traditional ♪
♪ busker playing guitar ♪
♪ emotional rock ♪
[music fades]
[light rain]
I like the texture here
and even if some of these buildings
are falling apart a little on the outside
you can see the structure
the craft, the thought, the design
the beauty behind them.
♪ industrial electronic ♪
Canvasing and going out without a map
and just getting into
whatever situation you get into.
♪ industrial electronic ♪
From my experience in Ukrainian cities
the looks of the buildings
usually drop pretty quickly
once you get out of the center
but in Lviv here
I've been walking for quite some time
and look at this.
I did a long walk out of the center
and just ended up
in this old wealthier neighborhood.
It was beautiful.
And so you can see
all the influences here.
All the influences in the architecture.
[music continues]
There's some art deco
and then this Austrian-Hungarian style
that's super impressive.
I had no idea this existed in Ukraine.
[birds chirping]
[street car clanking]
The history is absolutely [claps]
insane here.
SOLOMIA: We had the
Austria-Hungarian Empire here.
PETER: Right.
SOLOMIA: In the early 20th century.
Then 1914-1915 we had the Russians here.
The Russian Imperial Army was here.
Then the Austrians came back.
Then after the First World War
we had the Proclamation
of Ukrainian Independence.
It was the Western Ukrainian
People's Republic
that then joined the
Ukrainian People's Republic
and then we had the
Polish-Ukrainian War here.
Pols took the area over
and they stayed here
until the beginning
of the Second World War.
Then in 1939 the Soviets came here.
Weren't the Nazis here for a little bit?
-Yeah, in 1941.
-Right.
SOLOMIA: The Nazis came here.
They took the area over
and they stayed here until 1944.
Then in 1944 there was
the so-called liberation.
As the Soviets called it
but it was occupation for us.
Right.
And the Soviets stayed here
until the collapse
of the Soviet Union in 1991.
Wow.
I never thought
a cemetery could be so beautiful.
IVAN:  Yeah, yeah.
SOLOMIA: A hundred years ago
they didn't have Instagram or Facebook.
-How did they survive?
-[chuckles]
SOLOMIA: You know they wanted
everyone else to know
that they were a rich family
and so they bought
a very expensive plot of land
on the cemetery.
SOLOMIA: Then they built a family tomb
and this way people could see
that the family had very high status
in the society and they were respected.
So this is like 17th century...
Instagram or Facebook,
yeah if you look at it.
Here we go.
PETER: That would be the person with
like a million followers or something?
Probably even more I would say.
-So it's the same...
-More expensive than a Downtown villa.
♪ driving techno ♪
I absolutely love the murals here.
They're so beautiful
and many people from this part
of the world don't like the murals
'cause they're associated with communism
and they have a message behind them
but as an outsider I'm not connected
to them politically at all.
So I just see a beautiful mural.
Look at that.
[exhales]
-That's Soviet isn't it?
-It is Soviet.
SOLOMIA: And it's good.
♪ driving techno ♪
[streetcar clanking]
IVAN: Yay
PETER: Oh that's cool, look a that.
[door closes]
♪ heavy metal guitar ♪
SOLOMIA: Concrete jungle,
that's the area where I live.
From a tourist viewpoint
it might be interesting to go there
and snap all the Soviet tower blocks
but being an insider living there
it's not the best experience.
[heavy metal continues]
[men playing football]
PETER: It's super safe feeling.
I haven't met one panhandler.
I don't know if I've been lucky
but nobody's come up to me
and asked for anything
and I haven't seen one person
sleeping on the streets.
Like no homeless people
and they have to exist for sure.
It's interesting that this is
somewhat of a tourist city
and usually when that's the case
there are a lot of people
bumming for money
or sleeping on the streets
and I haven't seen it here.
So I'm curious,
do all those people get removed
and pushed outside of the center?
I don't know the story.
Ukraine's not the richest country
on the planet
and to see none of that
is really interesting
'cause you'll see way more of it
in Europe in general than you will here.
Homeless people,
it's pretty interesting because they...
They will help you or show you around.
They are trying to be helpful
-not just ask you for money for nothing.
-Right.
-They don't come off as homeless.
-Seriously I haven't seen one beggar...
-or homeless person here.
-It is true.
Which is bizarre.
Look at that pink Hummer,
how ugly is that thing?
Well, it happens.
PETER: No not her, this pink Hummer.
[laughing]
IVAN: Sorry, it's my judgmental nature.
I love the sounds here.
I like hearing those rail cars go by.
There's something in that.
[streetcar clanking]
But also the nature,
especially in these parks.
They're very lively, lots of birds.
Lots of just...
Maybe it's 'cause it's spring
but if feels like there's a good fusion
with the natural and the urban here.
♪ serene ♪
[birds chirping]
I swear to God there are
more older couples in love here
than pretty much anywhere else.
I've seen so many couples, older couples
holding hands, walking these streets
and smiling at each other.
I think there are a lot of
good family values
and just a lot of values in general
and maybe it's because
it's chiller here and more relaxed
and people have more time for each other
but it seems like...
A lot of the old people
have it sort of figured out.
[serene music continues]
[music fades into choir singing]
Look at these cool guys here in Lviv.
CHILD: Yeah boy.
[all laughing]
♪ deep piano ♪
Super cool city.
I just scratched the surface
here for three days
but from my outside eyes
I was highly impressed.
If you haven't been here
definitely come here.
If you're from here...
You're in a cool place,
you're in a cool city.
I was impressed.
That's my story on Lviv.
It was absolutely fantastic.
[piano continues]